economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio luis méndez sur y su buena noche
bienvenido comenzamos en eeuu y le
preguntó entonces qué conclusiones de la
reunión entre joe biden con
representantes sindicales y también
directores de empresas estadounidenses
raúl hay que señalar que para ello va a
ir en en la economía es una de las
prioridades y por ello señalado que los
sectores que mencionabas en jan
mostraron su compromiso para participar
de la recuperación económica no obstante
bardem señaló que lo primero que se debe
tener en cuenta es el control de la
pandemia asimismo volvió a pedir al
congreso la aprobación de un paquete de
ayudas para los distintos sectores de la
sociedad afectados por el cómic 19
mientras que el encuentro señaló que
destinará una inversión de al menos 300
mil millones de dólares en las nuevas
industrias y tecnologías con la
finalidad de crear alrededor de 3
millones de empleos y así mantener al
país como líder mundial en investigación
y desarrollo además habló de su
propuesta de comercio exterior
a ser consultado escuchemos
vamos a invertir en trabajadores
estadounidenses y hacerlos más
competitivos vamos a asegurarnos de que
la mano de obra y los ambientalistas
estén dentro de cualquier trato
comercial que hagamos no busco un
comercio punitivo tengo un plan bastante
completo pero lo anunciaré el 21 de
enero
jennifer's louis y 15 países de
asia-pacífico quemaron el mayor acuerdo
comercial del mundo esto se hizo en
vietnam durante la cumbre de la
asociación de países del sudeste
asiático para los expertos este acuerdo
estará liderado por china y no cuenta
con la participación de eeuu
la alianza integrador económica regional
supera a la unión europea o el tratado
comercial méxico eeuu y canadá este
concentrará alrededor de un 30 por
ciento de la economía mundial y tendrá
un universo aproximado de 2200
y consumidores este acuerdo eliminar
aranceles a las importaciones de los
miembros por los próximos 20 años e
incluye provisiones respecto a propiedad
intelectual telecomunicaciones servicio
financiero comercio electrónicos y
servicios profesionales además de china
y las naciones del sudeste asiático
en este acuerdo estarán participando
japón corea del sur australia y nueva
zelanda así eligen a más información
porque datos oficiales revelan un
aumento en la tasa de desempleo de perú
en el tercer trimestre y esto de acuerdo
con datos del instituto nacional de
estadística e informática de ese país
que indican que la tasa de desocupación
creció al 9 6% entre julio y septiembre
lo que se traduce en que más de un
millón de personas están buscando empleo
sobre todo en zonas urbanas los datos
emitidos reflejan un salto desde el 3.5
por ciento alcanzado en el mismo período
pero del año 2019 de acuerdo con
especialistas la imposición de
restricciones debido a la pandemia
generó un fuerte golpe en la economía
del país dado por el cierre casi total
de la actividad productiva
el producto interno bruto de la nación
cayó 65 por ciento en el mes de
septiembre si se compara con el mes
anterior adicionalmente el organismo
oficial reveló que entre el noveno mes
del año y enero la economía fue presentó
una caída de 14 49 por ciento en
comparación con el mismo período del año
anterior
así es luís díaz en francia pide
impuestos extraordinarios para el
estadounidense a amazon así lo señalan
algunos medios en base una propuesta que
surge de partidos políticos sindicatos y
también ongs estos grupos señalan que la
empresa de origen estadounidense está
incrementando sus ganancias debido a las
restricciones por la pandemia el anuncio
se hace en medio de una serie de
limitaciones que francia anunció
recientemente que se extenderán hasta el
próximo mes de diciembre por su parte el
secretario de estado para lo digital
señaló que el comercio en francia sólo
constituye un 10 por ciento del comercio
total en el caso del electrónico y
amazon representa tan sólo un 20% de ese
porcentaje
así es luisa ahora le pregunto por los
indicadores como cerraron este lunes
cerraron muy bien sobre todo por los
datos son mostrados por la farmacéutica
moderna entorno
vacuna que reflejó cierre es importante
sobre todo en wall street también en
europa y en américa latina fueron
cierres positivos así es como siempre
gracias por toda la información
económica que ustedes también gracias
por continuar con nosotros en france 24
[Música]